hello everyone if you've seen the movie
2001 a Space Odyssey directed by Stanley
Kubrick you might remember a short chess
scene being shown in the movie it was
played between astronaut Frank Poole and
the supercomputer Hal 9000 and they only
show a fraction of the game in the movie
but this is actually well based on a
real game the real game is a roach
versus Schlag played in hamburg in 1919
and 10 and the Stanley Kubrick was
actually a passionate chess player
himself so it's it's extremely cool that
he chose such a wonderful game to be
featured in his film and okay one other
interesting fact that the supercomputer
Hal 9000 is actually programmed to win
only 50% of the chess games that he
plays this is kind of an assurance to
boost the crews morale okay so let's see
this game Frank Poole is white and
supercomputer Hal 9000 is black we have
e4 e5 Knight to f3 Knight to c6 Bishop
to b5 so the rule opus will a saves the
Morphy defense Bishop play for Knight to
f6 Queen to d2
I will be five Bishop to b3 now Bishop
to e7
we have c3 black castles white castles
and we have d5 and here white plays a
combination that wins a pawn well it's
not really a combination but what is
pretty undeveloped here so he should
have probably have considered something
else he plays a captures on d5 we have a
knife counter Sun d5 and now Knight
captures an e5 so grabbing that pawn and
here the supercomputer Hal 9000 plays
Knight four and he attacks the Queen on
e2 we have Queen to e4 and now it seems
that this knight is pinned here if the
knight moves they Frank will grab this
rook and I ate but he'll doesn't mind
he'll plays a Knight captures on e5 and
he gives up the row can iead Frank
captures it we have Queen captures on a
eight and now Queen to d3 and well you
can see that this Queen on d3 is
completely blocking white from
developing any piece of whatsoever so
Frank tries a Bishop to d1 we have
we have Bishop the h3 and this Bishop
gh3 moved this is the position from the
movie you can check in the description
below I will put its 47 seconds clip so
you can see the original sequence from
the movie and ok he'll play Bishop to h3
and he opened up the attack on the
Frank's Queen so the threat is of course
rook captures an a8 but there is an even
greater threat and since Frank isn't
really a super Grandmaster he doesn't
really consider the position too much he
plays Queen captures on a6 and here
he'll says something like oh no I I
think you missed it Dave and he plays
Bishop captures on g2 we have rook to e1
and well now Hal 9000 plays Queen to f3
and the game is over I think this is
actually where health says it I think
you missed it dave is now well the
threat is Knight to h3 checkmate and
there is no way to stop this if if
Bishop captures Queens and simply this
Knight captures Bishop on f3 with
checkmate because this Knight is
defending this bishop from g2 so
definitely a beautiful position kind of
reminds you of Frank Marshalls American
Beauty only only a bit less beautiful so
yeah this is the game and luckily for
how this was as he only wins 50% of the
games he plays this is probably the
second game they played but Frank Poole
wasn't really disappointed as he doesn't
really expect to win any games and the
crew probably knows that hell is rigged
to only win 50% of the games so yeah
this is the this is the the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and I will try to
find one game played by Stanley Kubrick
himself that would be very awesome if I
could find that and I couldn't really
find any information and the original
players who played this game Rose
reverses Schlag it so if any of you have
any information maybe on those two
players I will be happy if you if you
could share it in the comments so yeah
that's it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here
think'll for watching and i'll see you
soon